I got it I bought a cameo from Chris
Hanson
you slipped through the cracks but I'm
Gonna Get You
all right so we're just gonna use this
article as an excuse to look at Kim
Kardashian photos what oh so is she
naked I don't like that dude apparently
well I don't like it let's talk about it
okay let's talk about it you don't think
she's the hottest woman on earth it is
now news by the way she might be for Kim
Kardashian just post pictures of herself
in the bikini and then everyone just
starts talking about it and then I could
spit into a [__] Fox News article in
here Fox News Fox News baby what's Fox
News spin on her yeah they're they're
saying that she's getting roasted in the
comments of her latest sexy Instagram
post so like literally she's getting
roasted so get this that's the news
she posts this picture on on Instagram
and a series of pictures like this okay
where she's looking all hot and stuff
like that and then so Fox News is going
into their [__] comments like here
just this we're those comments and going
she's getting roasted in there that's
news okay hold on and then there's who's
running that account I'm gonna read into
a news article
and then you see this
Kim Kardashian posted in teeny bikini
gets roasted online but the but the only
people roasting is people in her
Instagram comments and that's the news
it's just not incredible I like how you
presented that lawsuit baby what a time
we live in remember when everybody says
like oh man it's just getting so bad out
there and like we're like on this Peg
now we're on this page
Fox News turned into The National
Enquirer you know what's amazing if you
read the four comments that are actually
seen on here it's like you're hot fire
you're hot fire Emoji fire Emoji like
heart eyes heart eyes Yep Hot and then
oh hi Kim that's probably the meanest
thing so someone says honey she is just
happy that's a roast so that is a roast
or or somebody was like oh you could
save eight thousand dollars on
investigator this year I'm a Forex
Trader
you want to buy martial arts gear hey I
have supplies people should see like oh
man what is honestly the worst thing
that someone said
heed
[Laughter]
you know why they have to do this is
because they're friends with Kanye so
then now they're like that's my buddy
that's my boy yeah and he's getting
inflamed right now like yeah yeah good
point so it's like it's Maga Kanye
against Kim
who's fan base is a lot of sense we know
who's going to lose that fan base is
stronger I mean come on I mean everyone
here votes Kanye yeah
I literally just want him to be
president I literally would be the
greatest person of all time I wanted to
hit you vote for him nope I don't vote
what's up it's not tracks what sucks
about it is we have to wait for Kanye to
determine 83 so that he can be president
yeah yeah you have to have old ass
people as well yeah that's it do you
remember people were like Kanye couldn't
even be voted on the board of Calabasas
you know why because his ideas are too
radical no because they're like you're
trying to run for president yeah you
probably couldn't even run for like
Council of your own city that you live
in like they wouldn't vote Biden was
just here a couple days ago yeah you
[__] our buddy Aunt his dad is
chilling with them there's a photo with
them yeah pants does it yeah that's cool
oh is it cool where are you gonna go no
yeah you weren't gonna go I think he
came to go visit the whole the shooting
thing here for the shootout oh he
visited the guys huh did he visit the
dude that saved this yeah yeah I think
they got a photo together do you think
that guy's sick and tired of taking
pictures who the guy Brandon Brandon
said the guy that disarmed the [__]
he's like leave me alone you've got to
be traumatic yeah he's like the cool
dude like a regular dude that's what I
mean like he's just like all right bro I
don't gotta do any more photo ops I
don't want to hang out with Joe Biden
he's like I'll sign for kids but not if
you autograph Hound people yeah not if
you're gonna sell this on eBay yeah I
don't need the power but what if he gets
like political groupies now though you
know yeah so he's all getting like all
these like like Democratic booties yeah
he has a he has a cameo now yeah but he
could he does
what are the only fans now he's like hey
I hope you're
she's on your birthday
oh that always goes oh man that one was
oh that that hit me damn [__] oh you
don't have it you don't have a cameo he
does birthday shout outs I feel like
you're gonna go do I have a cameo no I
will tell you a true story I was God
asked for a while when I was on
stitchers like that was and also Cami
would just come out so it's very popular
and my manager was like don't do it
because then I can't negotiate for you
and I was like fair enough and I was
like that's why I have a manager so how
do I get you to tell my friend Happy
Birthday
you see you're gonna go through his
manager yeah
you have I need I need some Indian food
I need a matching jumpsuit I also want
another uh Super Bowl ring Super Bowl
ring this is about 75 dollar
conversation yeah no problem I got it I
bought a cameo from Chris Hanson
to tell my friend uh take a seat
to tell my friend that he was a molester
that got away
[Laughter]
you slipped through the cracks but I'm
Gonna Get You
that's it I had Brian I had Brian Cox
basically curse at my buddy for his
birthday who the guy the old man from
succession the main character you had
him curse him out yeah like as is like
it's Cameo thing like happy birthday you
[__] you fat [__] pig like
you know like the way he's on the show
because we were like just dude in
character we were like this is his name
say whatever you want just [__] on him
for one minute dude I got somebody
that's literally what we said I got I
paid 600 for OJ to tell my mom he's
gonna kill him great oh [__] 600 that's
it
great did it come with a glove that's it
huh and a ride in the white box that's
so cool
was he in the Bronco
he pulls up in the Bronco he's got like
a special edition Cameo with like the
arm and the gimbal on his car and he's
like
yeah how cool is that oh [__] man your
mom was like you do
oh my God you're my favorite son hey
Sherry I know it's your birthday
I got some sharp advice for you what was
the case that just happened on the news
the the father who who killed his his
son his wife I'm forgetting their name I
don't remember either probably like it
happens every week yeah but they they
went some news channel caught to OJ to
get his opinion on it what what I'm like
why don't people do it
I personally like to look at my victims
in the eye
allegedly of course yeah of course if I
were gonna do it real quick uh so in the
article the Fox News article they
proceed to just write down what people
in the Instagram comments actually oh my
God there's 40 going on 21 grow up
literally one wrote that's what the
article says roasted duck lit poses are
so 2012. said another roasted anything
to say semi-relevant right out of the
third wow by the way do you really think
Kim is semi-relevant
what the [__] is that I don't think
she's the [__] standard right now how
do you go on Kim Kardashian's page
you you imagine you open up your
Instagram you go to Instagram you're
following her you see her post this and
you're like oh yeah what what yeah you
think you're so relevant
you're a loser you're not relevant so
you know what's even worse is they don't
follow they hear a rumor that she posted
these pictures so they go and search go
on her page just to tell her that she's
irrelevant they're like this is a rich I
really I really want to know who was
like yo I'm gonna take this to my new
supervisor and I'm gonna convince them
that this is news and we're gonna put it
online for the whole world to see like
so there's a discussion where somebody
goes I have a great story and then
somebody else goes this is a great story
and then somebody else goes you're right
let's roll it so you're just and that's
three sources that's three people so
you're like so they're yeah because
they're they're idiot like they're like
in the The Writer's room or whatever
right and then one's like uh I got this
really good piece on Jeffrey Epstein and
then this other person's like I got this
Kim Kardashian everyone's like tell me
more about the Kim Kardashian yeah tell
me more tell me more they're like yeah
we know he didn't kill himself tell me
more about Kim
honestly it sounds like if I told my mom
to be as mean as possible that's
probably what she would write no like oh
you look old
or like oh is this inappropriate
or would she ever written this looks
good but you have a shadow on your chest
from your phone FYI oh
that hey that one's turn of the night or
she goes she goes oh my God Kim you look
great dot dot dot not
hahaha
it's like oh that one's better dude 40
million followers you don't have your
own lighting kit sorry
JK you know how are those comments still
up it's like borax
you look hot
damn dude what a great artist great
great response dude the Pinnacle of
Journalism
foreign